announcement such as that today uh and
further investment in renewables we've
seen uh investments slashed in in
renewable energy since the liberal
democrats left government in in 2015
this government has cut uh investment in
offshore and onshore wind and solar
power and so on so i'd like to see a lot
more in that that's absolutely key to
our growth that's where the jobs of the
future are going to be it's also key to
tackling fuel poverty which plays into
the cost of living crisis which we've
just been discussing
thank you all very much indeed well of
course uh before we get to that budget
statement we've just been discussing uh
we're going to have prime minister's
questions with me is our political
editor uh beth rigby and
this is not a position that boris
johnson really relishes being the
warm-up actor rishi sunak is it
no it's probably not but you know that
is his job today it is rishi-sanak's day
today and i think actually at pmq's
today
the prime minister has obviously got a
huge weekend and then week coming up he
will go to the g20
to meet leaders there will be no doubt
talked out talking about cop and also
about vaccines and covid he then has cop
next week in glasgow the big make or
break moment for a prime minister who
really has set his stall on getting
something meaningful out of this global
summit and i expect that that is
something that kierstama will press him
on he won't want to go on the economy
and the cost of living today that will
be uh the next thing after p.m
he's got a double job hasn't he because
this is the budget so he's got to
question the prime minister and then
he's going to answer the budget of the
opposition it's always difficult isn't
it as leader of the opposition to react
to the budget once you've been dazzled
uh by that uh stream of numbers
but kirsten will i think question the
prime minister on matters around cop
and then he will of course have to
respond to rishi sonak on matters of the
budget where no doubt they will talk
about the cost of living i'm sure it's
amazing you often see the league of the
opposition sitting on the benches having
people leaning over talking to him and
handing him notes and all the rest
i've got some breaking news here
um kia stammer has apparently tested
positive for covered this morning
and so won't be doing pmq's or the
budget response
literally just had that in
so that will be angela rainer
um imagine the shadow chancellor will be
drafted in i haven't got any more
information yet uh that's all i have
kirsten has tested positive for covert
this morning and so won't be doing pmq's
or the budget response
so will he he won't be doing promises
questions either we
assume
no and uh look at normally he might
choose to do it remotely um but
obviously he's actually he's not
isolating because someone in the
household's tested positive he's tested
uh positive for kovid this morning he's
not going to be in the chamber he's not
going to be doing it remotely as i said
angela rainer his deputy is also
not in westminster this week so i
suspect i imagine that it will be
rachel reeves that we'll have to step up
to the plate we'll find out imminently
we'll have to see because that's a very
interesting uh breaking news from beth
rigby there they're going to be no kiss
interrupt ed miliband is going to be
doing pmqs for labour ed miliband is the
people he's their business spokesman we
see him taking a seat he's going to be
doing prime minister's questions for
labor that the questions and for the
budget statement and then we'll have to
see whether edmund replies to the of
course uh as a former labour leader he's
done both in the past
is the prime minister number one is
dr neil hudson
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
during which my right honourable friend
the chancellor upgrade updated the
cabinet on how the government's plan for
jobs is working with higher wages higher
skills and rising productivity he will
make a statement of the house shortly
setting out how we will build a new age
of optimism mr speaker in addition to my
duties in this house i shall have
further such meetings later today
dr neil hudson
thank you mr speaker i very much welcome
the a66 northern trans-pennine project
from penrith to scotch corner this one
billion pound investment will improve
safety and congestion and help to level
up our region supporting jobs essential
services and tourism but we have to get
the project right
will my right honourable friend ask his
government departments for transport the
ministry of defense and defra to work
together pragmatically and reasonably
with suggested route amendments to
ensure local communities such as warcock
musgrave and sanford are not left
blighted by these current plans
mr speaker he's uh he's right that uh
the the development that he refers to as
part of a an infrastructure revolution i
think will transform the country but
he's also right that we should consider
local feedback uh from stakeholders and
the community when finalizing the design
and so we will
unfortunately the leader of the
opposition is isolating so i'm calling
ed miliband to ask the question i'll be
happy
thank you
[Applause]
just just like the old day
just to say i presume y'all want to get
onto the budget because all you're doing
is delaying it
i just want to reassure both sides of
the house it's one time only that i'm
back
mr
[Applause]
mr mr speaker we all need the vital cop
26 summit in glasgow to deliver next
week because failing to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees will have
devastating consequences for our planet
and that is shared across this house
does the prime minister agree that to
keep that goal of 1.5 degrees alive we
need to roughly halve global emissions
in this decisive decade
well i i welcome the right honourable
gentleman to uh to his place and indeed
i think i i think the whole house will
extend uh our sympathies to the to the
leader of the opposition hope he uh
returns uh returns soon uh it is of
course uh correct mr speaker that uh cop
26 is both
unbelievably important for our planet
but also very difficult and it's in the
balance uh mr speaker and uh he's right
in what he says about the need to keep
1.5 degrees alive and that will be and
it does depend on what happens this
decade it depends on the commitments
that are made all i will say mr speaker
is an already very substantial
commitment under the uk uh presidency
presidency designate of cop have been
achieved and we've moved from only 30
percent of the global economy uh
committed to a net zero by the middle of
the century tonight eighty percent and
uh every day as i talk to international
leaders we hear further commitments to
make those solid commitments that the
world will need whether it is enough mr
speaker i'm afraid it is too early to
say bill about mr speaker i applaud the
efforts of the uk presidency under the
president designate
sharma but but i do want to direct the
prime minister's attention to the issue
of this decade i'll come to net zero
targets for the middle of the century in
a moment but yesterday a very important
report came out from the united nations
which he will know the unep emissions
gap uh report and on the eve of cobb it
warned that far from halving global
emissions this decade we're only on
course to reduce them by about
7.5 percent does the prime minister
acknowledge because this is crucial for
what happens at glo glasgow and after
glasgow does the prime minister
acknowledge how far away we are from the
action required in this 10-year period
prime minister mr speaker indeed i do
but i think what the house should also
recognize is how far we have moved just
in the space of a few years since the
since the paris copper summit of 2015
where uh if as i'm sure the the right
honourable gentleman uh will remember
the world agreed to to net zero by 2100
by the end of the century and and agreed
and agreed to try to restrain global
warming by four degrees we're now trying
to keep alive the prospect of
restricting that growth to 1.5 degrees
every day mr speaker countries are
coming through with solid commitments on
stopping the output of of coal-fired
power stations uh reducing their use on
internal combustion engines planting
millions of trees and investing uh
hundreds of billions of pounds in the
developing world that is those are solid
crypts whether they're going to be
enough mr speaker i'm afraid it is still
i'm too early to say
i thought the commitments i just correct
the promise on one point it was the
second half of this century set out in
paris not 21 100 for net zero but but
here's the problem prime minister on
this question of net zero targets for
the middle of the century it's easy to
make promises for 30 years time it's
much more difficult to act now australia
has recently announced a 2050 net zero
target but its 2030 target would head
the world towards approximately four
degrees of global warming can i urge him
he mustn't shift the goal posts when it
comes to glasgow it is about the
emergency we face this decade it's about
the ndc's this decade
please keep the focus on 2030 not 2050
and beyond
[Applause]
the focus is certainly on on 2030 we
have 122 nationally determined
contributions already uh 17 out of 20 uh
g20 countries have made uh ndcs and and
the commitments are coming through and
he's right to say uh that we need to
keep the pressure up what you can't do
mr speaker is go in advance of what is
truly practicable uh for for the world
economy and for what and for what people
uh can do uh this government will go as
fast as we as we possibly can uh but it
was um labour's plans which i think he
he endorsed were condemned by the the
gmb union for
their their pay masters mr speaker uh
for for meaning that they'd be
confiscating people's cars uh by 2030
and you and families will be only
allowed one airplane flight every five
years mr speaker
mr speaker let me tell him
what this summit needs is statesmanship
not partisanship which we just heard
from the prime minister
that he should not be trying to score
party political points on such an
important issue facing our country and
our world
and that that's never the way i did
pmq's
now now let me ask him now let me let me
ask him about about the crucial issue of
climate finance for developing countries
because the the the reason that the
paris summit succeeded was there was a
coalition of vulnerable countries and
developed countries that put pressure on
all the big emitters including china
including india but the problem is that
the world has not delivered on the
hundred billion dollars of finance
promised more than a decade ago in
copenhagen that the plan is deliberate
maybe in 2023 but i want to ask him
about his actions i want to ask him
about his actions
hasn't it made it much harder to deliver
on this promise that we are the only g7
country to cut the aid budget in the
run-up to this crucial summit
[Applause]
this is big i thought we weren't going
to have any partisan points
didn't last long
actually the first the first thing i did
uh as one of the first things i did uh
as prime minister was to go out to uh my
first anger as prime minister's u.n
general assembly as prime minister and
announce uh a huge 11.6 billion pound
commitment from the uk to helping the
developed world to tackle climate change
and and
and i'm going to say to the right right
yes of course it's true
and we haven't cut that we have not cut
that mr speaker we're keeping that
investment we're keeping that investment
and and let me tell the right older
gentleman that this country is working
flat out to ensure that we do reach the
100 billion pound commitment from the
whole of the world we're seeing the
money come in from the united states
from the italians from the french from
from the european union and it's quite
right that it should we have a way to go
mr speaker whether we'll get there or
not i cannot say it's in the balance but
the challenge is there for the leaders
of the developed world and i quite agree
with the right gentleman they need to
rise to it
because it's one thing for him not to
know what is in the paris agreement but
it's another thing not to know what's in
his own budget he has cut the aid budget
of course he's cut
of course he's cut the aid budget he's
abandoned the bipartisan belief in the
aid budget across both of these houses
but it's not just on aid mr speaker
where they face both ways they've got a
trade deal with australia where they've
allowed them to drop their temperature
commitments
they're telling others to power past
coal while flirting with a new coal mine
and they're saying we've got to move
beyond fossil fuels and open the new
cambo oil field isn't the truth isn't
the truth mr speaker that the prime
minister has undermined his own cop
presidency by saying one thing and doing
another
[Applause]
no mr speaker
what what and he's completely wrong he's
completely wrong in what he's and i
think he should he should i think he
should withdraw what he just said about
the 11.6 billion uh because we remain
absolutely committed to the 11.6 billion
pounds that were investing to tackle
climate change around the world and uh
and if he and that is absolutely rock
solid and and he talks about australia
and i talked to the the prime minister
of australia the only reason and
australia has just with great difficulty
made the commitment to get to net zero
by 2050. it's a great thing and mr
speaker i talked to i talked yesterday
to our indonesian friends uh for
instance a jock over dodo good friend of
this country uh who's agreed on coal uh
to bring forward the the abolition of
coal use in indonesia to 2040. mr
speaker a fantastic effort by the
indonesians i talked to president putin
i think there was yesterday uh mr
speaker and he confirmed he confirmed
his determination to get to net zero uh
by the middle of the century and that
that is what the uk is doing working
with countries around the world to get
the outcome we want it's still too early
to say whether it will succeed mr
speaker it's in the balance
[Applause]
the thing the prime minister has
underestimated throughout these last two
years is cop 26 is not a glorified photo
opportunity it is a fragile and complex
negotiation
and
and the problem is
boost boosterism boot the prime
minister's boosterism won't cut carbon
emissions in half photo opportunities
won't cut carbon emissions enough can i
just say to the prime minister in these
in these final days before cop 26 we
need more than warm words above all
glasgow has got to be a summit of
climate delivery not climate delay
[Music]
he talks about cutting co2 in half well
that's virtually what this country this
government has done uh mr speaker since
1990 we've cut co2 by 44
and and the economy has grown by 78 and
that's our approach visiting a sensible
pragmatic conservative approach that
cuts co2 that tackles climate change and
that delivers high-wage high-skilled
jobs across this country and our our net
zero plan mr speaker will deliver 440
000 jobs that's what the people in this
country want us want to see and that's
what they're seeing they're seeing wages
up they're seeing growth up they're
seeing productivity up under this
government and if we and if we left it
to the to the right honorable gentleman
the leader of the opposition who is
sadly not in his place uh we would still
be in lockdown but it's a point that he
might he might bring to his attention
wherever he is currently self-isolated
stevenson
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will know that both i and my honourable
friend the member for wolverhampton
south west have lobbied for funding for
better training and skills provision for
young people in wolverhampton uh
unemployment rate youth unemployment was
unacceptably high pre-pandemic and now
sadly is the highest rate nationally
would the prime minister urgently look
at how the government can level up
opportunity so that young people in
wolverhampton can get the skills and the
confidence they need to find work
[Applause]
[Music]
my honorable friend is absolutely right
about wolverhampton that's why we're
working flat out uh to ensure that uh
young people in wolverhampton benefit
from the kickstart kickstart scheme and
uh we are working with wolverhampton
council to ensure uh that young people
get bespoke support for their return to
work
we now come to the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the
thoughts and prayers of the entire house
will be with the family of walter smith
who sadly passed away yesterday the
legend that was the rangers done united
and scotland manager and many of us will
not forget the day that he led us to
victory over france at hampden mr
speaker
naturally
most of today's focus and attention will
turn to the
chancellor's budget after prime
minister's question but before we
turn to domestic matters
i think it's right and important to
raise the dire
humanitarian situation
that is developing in afghanistan
the world food programme estimates that
more than half the population
about 22.8 million people face acute
food insecurity 3.2 million children
under 5
could suffer acute malnutrition
given the history of the last 20 years
it should be obvious that we have a deep
responsibility to this country and to
its people
mr speaker they are dying
and they need our help
it is only two months since the allied
forces relinquished control of the
country
so can the prime minister update us
on what exactly his government is doing
to end the famine in afghanistan
i i thank the right honourable gentleman
and he raises uh a uh an insider that i
know is on the minds of many people in
this house and across the country we're
proud of what we've done to to welcome
people from afghanistan but we must do
everything we can also to mitigate uh
the uh the the consequences uh for the
uh people of afghanistan of the taliban
take over and so what we did as you as
you will recall is we doubled our uh age
commitment for this year to 286 million
pounds and we're working with the
un agencies and other ngos to do
everything we can to to help the people
of afghanistan what we can't do at the
moment is uh write a a completely blank
check to the taliban government taliban
authorities uh we need to ensure that
they that country does not slip back
into being a haven for terrorism and a
narco state
mr speaker the fact is there is a
humanitarian crisis and people are in
need today there is nothing there about
tangible actions that the government is
taking on the ground now because the
situation is getting worse by the day
in august
the allies ran away from the
responsibilities in afghanistan and now
it very much feels like this government
is washing its hands of the legacy that
it left behind
because
not alone are the afghan people being
failed on humanitarian aid promises made
to them on resettlement are also been
broken too the afghan citizens
resettlement scheme was announced on the
18th of august which talked about
resettling up to 20 000 in the coming
years
but more than two months on mr speaker
we've heard nothing
the afghan people are being left with no
updates and vague targets
so can the prime minister
finally tell us
when the resettlement scheme will open
can he guarantee guarantee prime
minister that 20 000 afghans will be
resettled and when exactly is the
deadline for that to happen
[Applause]
mr speaker we made a commitment to
resettle uh 20 000 afghans in addition
uh to those that we brought out under
operation fitting which i think most
people most fair minded people in this
country would think was a pretty
remarkable feat by uk armed services and
many of them are many of the of those 50
000 15 000 are already being integrated
into uh into the uk into into schools
into into communities and we will help
them in any way that that we can and one
of the reasons and he i'm afraid he's
completely wrong in his characterization
of the the the stance the uk has taken
towards afghanistan and the change and
the changes there we continue to engage
uh we engage with the taliban this
country was the one of the first uh to
to reach out and begin a dialogue and
what we what we what we are insisting on
is safe passage mr speaker
what we are insist and just to get to
his point where he rather
uncivilly calls out uh what we are
insisting on mr speaker is that there is
safe passage for those who wish to come
and settle in this country for people to
whom we owe an obligation and that is
what we are doing mr speaker and i have
answered the question
[Music]
thank you
as the whole house will know today is
national cheese toasty
a massive
it's a fact a massive 4.3 billion
toasties were consumed last year they
are the nation's favorite snack and
glorious somerset is the home of cheddar
cheese so with the news that white farms
in my constituency is now producing what
i think is the world's first entirely
carbon neutral
cheddar cheese
didn't my writing friend know that
eating cheddar from somerset can reduce
your
your cheese consumption carbon footprint
by 55 percent so will my right-handed
friend support our vital dairy industry
by committing to enjoying the kabul
neutral cheese toasty today
well mr speaker my only question is why
is it only national cheese toasty day
why isn't it international cheese toasty
day
and i i hope very much that uh amongst
its many achievements the cop 26 summit
uh will bring the bring the entire
global community uh to a better
understanding of the white farms carbon
neutral uh cheese toastie so jeffrey
donaldson
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
will be aware of the harm that the
northern ireland protocol is doing to
the political and economic stability of
northern ireland
and the very delicate constitutional
balance created by the belfast or good
friday agreement in the command paper
published by the government in july
they committed to addressing these
issues and recognized that the protocol
is simply not sustainable
does the prime minister accept that the
conditions now exist to trigger article
16 of the protocol
in the event that the current
negotiations with the eu failed to
arrive at an acceptable outcome
the the right honourable gentleman is is
completely right uh i'm sad to say in
what he says and uh we're working hard
to secure
an agreement by negotiation uh but we
need to uh see real progress because he
knows the the real life issues on the
ground in northern ireland haven't uh
gone away and
if we can't see progress as we've been
saying now for some months if we can't
see rapid progress uh in the way that we
spelt out in our command paper then i i
think that it's clear to everybody that
the conditions for invoking article 16
have already been met want me more thank
you mr speaker the airedale hospital in
my constituency is made predominantly
from aerated concrete which is known for
its structural deficiencies and is now
in desperate need of a new rebuild as
the prime minister will be aware the
airedale hospital recently submitted its
bid to government for a brand new carbon
neutral hospital it is fantastic news
that this conservative government will
deliver 48 new hospitals but can i make
an urgent plea to the prime minister
that the airedale is one of them
[Applause]
uh well we have been speaking here with
my older friend we're hearing a little
bit more indeed the whole house will be
hearing uh more about uh the the
spending for health in in just a few
moments but i can tell him uh that we've
received 120 applications for the
biggest hospital building program in a
generation and uh his uh application
will certainly be amongst those who will
get our most urgent consideration
thank you mr speaker this government is
failing women and girls from lack of
rape prosecutions no victims bill
to letting criminals off the hook
and now women and girls including my own
children
are being targeted with a sinister
form of spiking through injections
it's always women and girls who pay the
heaviest price
now they are taking a stand today and
saying enough is enough
so how many more women and girls will be
hunted
or excluded
before the prime minister himself
finally takes a stand
mr speaker the reports of spiking are
extremely disturbing and as the
honourable lady knows it's already
a criminal offense and i know that the
home sector my run from the home
secretary has asked the police to update
her on exactly uh what details they have
of what is happening she wants to give
them the space for the time being uh to
conduct their their inquiries into
what's going on but i would ask
everybody with information about such
incidents to come forward and contact
their local police
morris
with cop 26 being imminent i would like
to draw attention to what good works
being done in morkan with eden project
wes johnson at morkum and lancaster
college has put forward a program to
teach youngsters in morecambe
the international eden ethos to shall we
say propagate the
the goodwill around the world i'd like
to invite the prime minister to come to
malcolm and come to the malcolm river
area to see the eden project site at the
earliest convenience thank you
mr speaker i'm delighted to respond uh
in the affirmative but to my honourable
friend because i think the last time he
asked me about this it was to ensure
that we got need and project uh in
morecambe so it stands for what he's
saying is that as though we're making
progress in that direction that uh that
is thrilling
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the whole
house will want to send my right
honourable friend the leader of the
opposition our best wishes
and it's also good mr speaker to see a
few more conservative mps heeding the
health secretary's plea and wearing
masks
but given we have had for several weeks
now covert infection hospitalization and
death rates far far higher than any
other western european country was it a
mistake to abandon all those precautions
back in july and if not why are our
figures so bad
uh mr speaker i i
thank the honourable general of his
question but uh the reality is that of
course uh we uh monitor all the data
very carefully every day but we see
nothing uh to suggest that we need to
deviate from the the plan that we've set
out uh
that began with the the road map in
february and that we are sticking to
that has given uh business and given
this country uh to get on uh and achieve
uh the unlockings that we've seen and
indeed the fastest economic growth in
the g7 james
speaker my love for constituents sophia
dede has composed a song about the
positive action we can each take to
combat climate change which emphasizes
the need to clean protect
repair and protect will the prime
minister join me in encouraging all uk
schools to follow the lead of fairfield
prep school in loughborough and other
schools across the world from hawaii to
norway in raising awareness of this
important issue through learning the
song
uh yeah well yes mr speaker do i have to
learn the song
i'll do my best to speak and i i thank
uh my honourable friend for raising the
work of her constituents in her and her
constituent school and it is absolutely
vital that we not only uh recycle where
uh it's sensible but above we cut down
on the use of plastics mr speaker
thank you mr speaker this week it was
revealed that fossil fuel companies
interest groups and climate denialists
have donated 1.3 million pounds to the
conservative party and its mps since
2019.
so a simple question no waffling or
dodging the issue on the eve of cop 26
will the prime minister demonstrate that
he is serious about tackling the climate
emergency by paying back this money and
pledging that his party will never again
take money and donations from the fossil
fuel companies that are burning our
planet yes or no
mr speaker all our donations are
registered in the normal way and i just
remind her that uh the labour party's
pay masters
the gnb
think that labour's think labour's
policies mean that no families would
have only to take one flight every five
years mr speaker and have their cars
confiscated welcome because
thank you mr speaker
uh this week it's uk wind week and later
later this afternoon
later this afternoon i'll be welcoming
some young people from my constituency
who are who see their futures in the
renewable energy sector which has done
so much to level up the grimsby cliffs
and north east
will the prime minister give an
assurance that the government will
continue to invest in the skills and
development of our young people to
benefit the uh
regional uh renewable energy sector
[Applause]
uh yes mr speaker and i think the whole
house should be proud of the fact that
the the uk now produces more offshore
wind that still produces more offshore
wind than not not hot air mr speaker uh
but energy for the people of this
country uh clean green energy uh
produced off cleethorpe's offer in the
north sea and we're going massively
going to be increasing the volume of
that output mr speaker steven kenner mr
speaker a thriving steel industry is the
foundation of a more productive and
resilient britain yet bickering between
the chancellor and the business
secretary is blocking the chance to
tackle the sky-high energy prices that
our steel makers have been facing since
long before the current price spikes
with a pathway to next zero dependent on
steel firms using more electricity not
less will he urge his colleagues around
the cabinet table to now put in place a
wholesale energy price cap
along with long overdue reductions in
network connection costs mr speaker cop
won't work without a cap
well mr speaker he's making a very
important point about the high energy
costs for uh for energy intensive
industries and that's why we've abated
them but with about 2 billion pounds
since 2013 but the answer is to do what
we're doing uh to make up the long-term
baseload needs of this economy by
investing in in nuclear which i'm afraid
and labor failed to do in their 13 uh
lost years mr speaker as well as in
renewables